we're incredibly trained and incredibly
good at making simple [ __ ] complicated
which then [ __ ] us at scale what's up
everybody welcome to the refurbished
first episode of the askgaryvee show
which let's call it what it is should be
a show where people ask me questions
like it was for the first 300 episodes
or so and by the way Jim on that note
let's get at least one askgaryvee show
into the Facebook live recap thing that
we do to see the spikes to put on
Instagram what a format that was when a
big shout-out to Steve Unwin and India
and Stefan and all the other characters
that were part of that show d-roc still
here and so we're back as you now know
my podcast interview show is now taking
two forms either interrupted by Gary Vee
which I'm actually already rethinking
too because people really get mad at me
for interrupting and I really need to
consider it to try to get better then
just the audio experience where I just
interview people cuz that's the mood but
I'm bringing back the askgaryvee show
and here's how it is for everybody
watching right now and I know you're
watching Instagram what up tick tock
what up Twitter what's up LinkedIn and
Facebook one is up right this second
text me on my community app two one two
nine three one five seven three one two
one two nine three one five seven three
one two one two nine three one five
seven three one two one two nine three
one five seven three one two one two
nine three one five seven three one text
right now Zayn is literally in my app
signed in as me right now looking for
your questions he's reading him he's
gonna take his favorite question so it
literally texts me right now with the
question that you have
he's literally reading I'm making a
subjective call of which one he likes
I'm gonna call you right now and I'm
gonna answer your [ __ ] question
that's the askgaryvee show you're gonna
ask a question when i go live randomly
this is random I'm live vain most often
but somebody else sometimes as well I
guess we'll read it the questions are
any coming in Zayn thank you a lot of
you don't text me haven't signed up for
my text platform so this is the time to
want to
three one five seven three one you're
starting get some questions yeah you
like something already yeah one [ __ ] it
call Sally this is it is what we're
doing now this is where some of the best
content has ever come from this is where
the most help comes from I'm at my
strongest when I ask answer questions
who's this good hello Matt it's Gary Vee
you're on the askgaryvee show
reboot episode 1 or maybe not I don't
know how the team's gonna do it how are
you
I'm incredible how are you Matt I'm so
good I've good news in your Wikipedia
one day it will say that you were the
first caller on the askgaryvee reboot
episode 1 show what do you think about
that this is crazy I was just watching
you on LinkedIn and I'm like in my
family talking to you I love it brother
what's your question my question is so
I'm currently I just recently moved to
New York City back in August and I've
been working to add Executive Assistant
Kathleen company and so I'm really just
trying to get kind of my feet under me
and find a place to be because that job
recently moved from Brooklyn to Staten
Island so I'm looking for somewhere else
to be in so my question is how do I
stand out in the interview process I say
a couple ways everybody [ __ ] up
interviews cuz they fake cuz they try to
conform to the job instead of tripling
down on who they are so in a world where
everyone's reverse-engineering the judge
and they're giving answers they maybe
should see people come to me when they
interview with me all they do is
regurgitate [ __ ] that I've put out on
the internet thinking I'm gonna like it
when I can sense they're full of [ __ ]
right so you need to bro you need to be
a hundred percent you and it's a numbers
game I don't understand how people don't
understand this send five [ __ ]
thousand resumes on LinkedIn and
Instagram DM to the five thousand places
you want to work aka the thirty nine
places you want to work and every single
person that can make a decision in those
companies bro this is a great
opportunity like if you just move back
and you're in this predicament this is
your chance to actually take how old are
you I'm 22 even better
bro what are your three favorite things
in life like sports wine you know what
are you what do you like well I like ten
years okay okay I loved it and the thing
is is that I did that in Massachusetts
it just moved from Massachusetts to New
York I think I want it to you know I
just graduated college I love actually
promote justice in psychology I love
that I did a lot of nonprofit work and
so I was doing things with that I love
working with kids I love those three
things you have to go work at a UFC
training facility yeah I think I mean
you love psychology you love kids you
love mixed martial arts right yeah I in
my condo bro don't be a dick go into
that field being an executive admin for
a [ __ ] scaffolding company is no
different in being an executive admin
right now at Rumble for Eugene or at
some [ __ ] I don't know like there's
probably 700 [ __ ] gyms yeah happy
there and that's just like nibble on
like that I just I just wasn't happy
same working crazy hours just doing
things that I look I didn't meet any
gasoline company are we talking about
didn't like it shucks it was nice to
copy here a little money so it looks
kind of search for the next month and by
the way saving money thing like one of
the things I think a lot about it yeah
dude and it's that month is gonna go
like this which is why I love side
hustles at night like to me bro are you
living at home living with somewhere my
my girlfriend and I have an apartment
right Queen so what we're doing that
right one strategy to think about is
what can you do from 6 p.m. to like 10
p.m. as a side hustle or is a [ __ ]
job just to pay for your rent and
whatever minimal food you need to eat
until you get that my biggest concern is
you save for a month now you're holding
your breath you don't find a good job
you're gonna take another [ __ ] job
in two months
worried to pay for rent this is what
everybody does they go into a jail right
which is why I don't want to also like
just take anything that I can get at the
same time have that awesome so you need
the ability I get a brother so you need
a framework from 6:00 p.m. to 10 p.m. so
you can spend 8 a.m. to 6 p.m. to get
that job this is why I love flipping so
much this is why I love humility and
working at 7-eleven at a 24-hour
convenience store and living in a shitty
place I want people out of the jail of
[ __ ] taking a job they don't like
just to pay for [ __ ] an apartment
with their girlfriend right absolutely
and I think I've got a lot of like
auditing because I've been following you
can probably like four or five years now
and I've just kind of really audited
myself because I was on that kind of
like kick of like wanting to do
something like I wanted to do my own
thing and I'm like Rihanna realizing I'm
coming to terms with the fact that I'm
not that person I'm the person more so
to support yeah yes I feel I'm better at
that so hey I love you for that
self-awareness and it makes me feel so
good because as even though I'm the
entrepreneurs entrepreneur literally two
different people came to me in Miami
this weekend and said my favorite
entrepreneur you're their favorite
entrepreneur you know and I was like oh
yeah I've seen that another that like
stuff like your athletes favorite
athlete that was like oh [ __ ]
but what I'm so pumped about is I'm
actually putting out content to make
people not be entrepreneurs when they're
not I want to talk about self-awareness
not entrepreneurship I want to talk
about happiness not making money brother
listen to me figure out a way to make
money from 7:00 p.m. to midnight whether
that's eBay the flips it's real between
or some 24 hour [ __ ] job so right
this is the game do that in parallel
with spending 7:00 a.m. to 6 p.m. on
hitting up every single person in
martial arts and mixed martial arts that
you could be the admin for well what if
I don't want to go down that road the
criminal justice route and and the the
marketing side that I've done with with
worked in the past my nonprofit work
done things like that and
get more so we try we trying to go are
we trying to go as literal as you want
to do the marketing for a law firm maybe
apply administrative work in a lot well
I really say it because I had a
connection back in Boston that him and I
spoke a lot for a company here in New
York City and so that we've been kind of
talking about that why why why because I
think not now why not why not sash it
answer why my concern my concern if I
could be transparent is you may think
there's money in it nothing you said
prior got me excited about real estate
okay I could be wrong
we're just doing the askgaryvee show
here but but why not is a horrible
answer and a lot of people use that as a
catch-all for what they're really saying
which is this might be able to make me
some money
other people have made money in it I
might want to do it well I've respected
the guy who spoke to me in the
connection I made back in when I was
living in Massachusetts and the value
that he projected was nope being in that
position when people are in the real
estate situation when they're trying to
the company itself the industry and I've
always been a supporter of trying to you
know cut the [ __ ] out and cut all
that out and be you know the best person
in that field whether it's like doing
doing the good doing the good thing
that's the first seed of something where
okay you're gonna use a very macro point
of view to justify why I respect a lot
of people I don't want to do that thing
for the majority of my life
right just cuz you voice echoes does
that go back to like the tasting like if
you're like mildly insert it or do you
think that like total [ __ ] because
look it all comes down honestly this
whole game comes down to how much
humility
you have are you and your girl willing
to live in a even worse apartment for
the next eight years and are you willing
to work at 7-eleven or something yet or
wait tables for eight years
because tasting sounds fun on paper but
the way you're talking about it is is a
very structured way where you're gonna
have to do everything for a year or two
so you taste for things in eight years
whereas if somebody's really willing to
go humble doesn't have a significant
other is willing to live on couches they
can be rogue as [ __ ] because they have
no expenses you put yourself in a jail
you have rent right you have a mental
jail of the perception potentially of
not being able to afford that rent and
having to live with your parents or
somebody else that may look bad to your
girl and/or everybody around you you're
creating a jail so that leave that
limits your tasting ability to maybe
four things in eight years right do you
have the humility and patience to step
back after at the age of thirty and
saying okay I've done criminal justice
real estate mixed martial arts and
sports cards because I'm into it and say
[ __ ] I don't like any of them do you
have the ability to double down to 35
that is [ __ ] mental [ __ ] power
that the far majority people don't have
and I don't want to impose my mental
prowess on others which is why I want to
talk through this in an articulate way
to bring as much value to as many people
as possible predicated on how I roll
right now there's a lot of things you
can do with that information you can
have a conversation with your girl and
say listen we need to cut our costs to
zero how are we gonna do that who's our
best friend from school then that lives
here can we crash with them I have no
idea where parents live or others older
siblings like this is the game of making
it operational right happiness has to be
the ROI brother absolutely and that's
why that's like right now I'm focusing
on what specifically looking at places
to to work I know I'm thinking I think
I'm thinking long-term rather than just
putting it all out there and applying as
many places
all right I'm correct in a game of nose
you have to try to get as many yeses as
possible you have no
options yet right everybody over things
sitting there trying to like here's what
happened we live in a society of so much
fruitfulness over the last 30 years and
school is fake that people think they
actually have more options than they do
because the system is now not in your
favor it's not telling you what to do
it's an open slate so what you have to
do is [ __ ] spray not pray spray and
wait if I love a job in right this
minute in the world I'm applying to a
thousand places in a day right
people are [ __ ] talking to me about
like getting a resume together look at
the [ __ ] are you talking about
geom 500 people LinkedIn 500 people and
I really tell them the truth about who
you are you the humility and strategy
which i think is smart to be an admin or
right hand the world is your [ __ ]
oyster I would [ __ ] DM dana white and
reply yo I will eat [ __ ] for 24 months
and close every [ __ ] gap in your life
like a [ __ ] dog if you give me a shot
guess what if God willing dana white by
accident saw that DM on what i just told
you to write you're getting that job
yeah and then you do that is just
increasing that chance and you end up on
Team Gary day I apply for apply again
thank you brother
you got it thank you Gary god I love the
askgaryvee show there's nothing like it
I don't even want to [ __ ] work
anymore I think this is just literally
what I want to do for a living Zane come
on you shouldn't need to be a little bit
more on top of it um that's right
raghav looks like let's not have any
dead space talk to me about what's going
on a LinkedIn just in general
observations while we wait for [ __ ]
Zane Oh
oh yes well I had the money for the spot
it was like all my money and I was gonna
do it but I didn't know that you had to
buy another 50 million dollars worth of
[ __ ] television just to get that
opportunity to buy the Super Bowl spot
it would be right I'll do it right now
it aired yesterday America what's up
it's Gary Vee I want to know you and
bring you as much value as possible
here's my phone number two one two nine
three one five seven three one text me
also here's all my social follow me I
talk about self-awareness and happiness
and making it unbelievably practical I
want to be your friend America I'm Gary
Vee I'm consistent if anything hello
hello Gary
yes is Melo's well it's very nice to
meet you my friend how are you
tremendous what can I help you with and
I'm pursuing this career and I've always
been interested in different staffing in
the films and the media and public
relations but I decided to go ahead and
just pursue the legal career early why
you know like because my dad wanted to
do I'm never gonna lie I think that's
what's the reason cuz you know I thought
how does the stable profession and you
know I of course I think I hit some
interest and all the dicks or whatever
but now I'm here and man I'm I didn't
know I just I didn't know the thing I
want to do no [ __ ]
of course that's not you did it cuz your
dad wanted you to write is your dad in
Poland yeah
perfect so just tell your dad you're
doing it and do something else all right
well I think you should do something
else oh yeah so Mike yeah what
right now I'm I was thinking today just
yeah I was thinking about you just
applied to different entertainment
companies and just work there is some
you know legal in a legal position I
look let me know sound like what you're
doing cuz I was joking a little bit
about the dad thing but not really I
mean
it was a hot take but if we need to talk
here a little bit but I like the idea of
leveraging what you've already invested
and how long have you been in law school
I completed my first year so look the
beauty is you're in Atlanta which is
becoming the new Hollywood so there's a
ton going on it's there is potential if
you apply to 200 places for somebody
wanting to give you an internship or a
low paying job for the summer or
full-time if you can handle the both and
Eastern Bloc kids tend to be able to
handle both things cuz they're not fancy
and I think it's a great idea to
leverage what you've already invested in
to get in the door and then once you're
the junior man in the legal department
you start working the halls of the
agents and the creative people and you
start shooting the [ __ ] and and over
time no question can you go from a legal
path to maybe being a strategist or a
creative if you have that natural talent
what would you recommend I do apply to
every single entertainment company in
Atlanta on LinkedIn their website or
DMing the founder okay what do you think
about the clients to bring their media
well we're not looking for anybody
illegal okay alright are you looking to
move uh yeah
I'm you know I'm an immigrant but I've
really had like one plate yeah I'm just
I was looking whatever I get but I want
you going to school won't you have to go
back to my country in law school yeah
so if I said yes you would come up here
and transfer to a different law school
hi yeah if I could get it out there and
work for you then yeah alright just
email me Gary of vaynermedia and I mean
an entry legal job here I'm not sure
what that pays versus the balance of
like how much that takes away from your
studies but you can email me but let me
tell you right now I mean the title put
polish kid looking for a legal job but
I'm telling you right now in Atlanta is
[ __ ] loaded if you care about
entertainment okay look
beside from Jacqueline two places do you
think I should have to just hit up
people and try to network and call them
and yes that's what I said I said apply
on LinkedIn in their website and then DM
the founders on the Instagram okay do
you like hip-hop music yeah I absolutely
do rock this moment like I actually was
doing concert can you rap right now for
me a little bit
you need a beat no I got it I got it
you give you compete for cancer
community oh damn I get it everything
stressful in life but yeah listen me if
you love hip-hop and you're in Atlanta
and and you've got some legal ability
but you're also Eastern European rugged
I promise you the south side of Atlanta
will [ __ ] with you I would hit up the
best entrepreneurs whether they're Jeezy
or 2 Chainz bro it's the same advice to
everybody when you are blaming of being
in something the entryway is either
praying through resume or hitting up
decision-makers that love humility and
bravado right like the last kid that
just called Dana White the same thing
for 2 Chainz and Ji
easy and Coach K you understand yeah
real fast okay so I also started because
I was thinking about getting I was I
listened to your crashing it
yes and I was thinking okay I'm in law
students I'm interested in media I want
to get myself out there so I started my
English website I mean Facebook and
always Facebook about my name yours
Albert G American law blog and often
always problematic anxious just to talk
about what's going on in the United
States and actually also schedule they
talk to us with one of my distinguished
law professors and what do you think
about that you also get noticed you
should you should do that every day
multiple times a day okay
go get a meal okay you're welcome let's
keep it going
what else do you Ock what do you got in
this come on yes I was super bowl good
what do you it's called entitlement
it's called entitlement people think cuz
they invested in a degree that that
application with the resume is what the
ROI of that was because they don't
realize that that degree almost means
nothing to 87 percent of the actual
world there are absolutely degrees that
are ry+
you go to a huge brand like Harvard and
Stanford I promise you
Goldman Sachs and VC firms and other
people gonna look at it the problem is
there's about 15 to 25 schools and about
15 to 25 professions that that works for
and then there's the rest of us and the
rest of us used to win in 1983 because
that fit
18:15 was actually 150 150 and what I
mean by that is what you're talking
about is the lack of humility from the
masses to do something they love right
it's like John right next to you right
like he got in and even was thinking
about moving quickly because he thought
he had the equity until he was
enlightened there's like [ __ ] wait a
minute more equity I agree
we haven't calibrated the internet you
couldn't be M [ __ ] Dana White in 1987
and he actually sees it and he actually
might consider it because there's so
many more entrepreneurial weird
characters making decisions it was also
the judge even he had the Internet in 84
but everybody was to still decision
makers they were going through a
corporate robotic if I don't see this
College on the resume you're out because
they're like because they're like Dana
give me a job 100% you're more likely to
respond than me and now because you're
so [ __ ] big time you know now
seriously though you were responding to
everybody I'm sure I first cuz it's
[ __ ] cool just like I responded every
single [ __ ] Ewing for six years I
played every single email from 2007 to
2011 four years every tweet four years
all of that I still get anxiety when
people write Gary doesn't text me back
now this is the best show yeah I don't
even want it [ __ ] don't bring you
[ __ ] guest number against
interrupted cancelled audio canceled
only a scary me it's the best show it's
the most value tell me if I'm right
hello Jackie its Gary Vee yeah Gary yes
Jack my god yes Jackie yes
[Music]
by doing that so well were you from then
what's up I love it
what's cooking jack so my question so my
question is I have a corporate job but I
have all these that I feel my husband
when I get home I wake up extra early
and you know do all of that and
everything but I'm wanting to start
documenting and like putting out the
videos and I've never been starting
filming the video but I don't want to
upload things because I'm afraid that
because my job does keep tabs up because
like I even started like my ABC business
and we saw our chives and everything and
I started promoting that and they caught
on they're like hey is this cutting easy
it's time like at your job
and I was like uh no it's not of course
not very casual I really like hustling
from a meeting and going to make sure
like I found my stuff ready quite yet
and then I'm going out and Jackie that I
love it it comes down to the job right
there's [ __ ] in this wing that I know
we're doing [ __ ] on the side while
they're supposed to be and they work
hard let alone what's going on in Vayner
that work more standard hours and
they're doing their own side [ __ ] and
I'm cool with it we did have to put in a
side hustle policy because we became
boning because so many people were doing
[ __ ] that some of our client contracts
for like I was actually but I wasn't mad
that like you know Sid was working on
something for an hour that was you know
and so the reality is you may here's my
big thing get out of jails the theme of
today is get out of jails self-imposed
jails kid number one has a rent that he
has to pay with his girl at 22 that I'm
concerned is too expensive right you you
most like you most likely can get
another job in your field that may be
more open to you working after work on
your stuff and don't have cynicism and
quick trigger blame and thinking that
you're working on their side my dad
doesn't want wine library employees to
actually have their phone on them in the
store because he's scared that in there
hours that they work in a store they're
not gonna work for even two minutes when
they're looking at their phone that's my
dad
I on the other hand have no idea what
the [ __ ] anyone's doing well yeah yeah I
get that so I get to get out of selling
this little Explorer and just kidding in
my case it's just like this I don't like
I wanna leave this job because because
um I right so don't so don't do your
side stuff yeah so don't do your side
stuff because there's gonna be scrutiny
or go to the tippy-top and say I work my
face off every minute while I'm here
know that I'm doing stuff when I get
home instead of watching Netflix being
in between and guessing okay is gonna
keep you in fear you only have one or
two options check this jegi this is
what's so awesome that life once you get
into a binary framework you either have
the I'm gonna get another job
and I'm going to tell them up front that
I work from 6:00 p.m. on so just know
what you're getting into with Jackie I'm
[ __ ] Jackie this is how I go or you
go to the tippy-top in your police then
you like right now and say hey I know
that this is flared up before when I was
doing the Airbnb thing look at my face
I'm Jackie from 9 to 5 I work every
minute when I go home I work also
everything is sick my lack of education
and my lack of fear is the reason I'm so
successful in business I only have
simple I'm only simple because it's
actually simple we're incredibly trained
and incredibly good at making simple
[ __ ] complicated which then [ __ ] us at
scale yeah just over it right it's that
simple kinda looking if I'm if you're my
sister I'm like okay and before you go
have that conversation with the top
telling them what you do let's go take
15 interviews and have two jobs lined up
in case they look you in the face and
say [ __ ] you yeah yeah yes I'm gonna do
that I'm gonna do that
Jackie email me when you do it
and tell me what how worked out okay
yeah I will thank you you're welcome
Jeff have a great day okay YouTube about
you yeah keep it movin best show ever
single best show on the Internet
how's it reaction how people feeling oh
hello Scott
I'm tremendous how are you I can't wait
so my question to you like that
do some work together a lot of pages and
ideas and my biggest fear is that we get
into an argument or disagreement and it
kind of ruined the relationship that
something like that well he's an amazing
guy I know you worked with your adapter
many years so what kind of advice could
you give me to make sure you know we're
maintaining that relationship and that
all right I got a lot of opinions and
thoughts and observations that I hope it
brings you value so let's start with a
couple more questions
have either of you done real estate
before I didn't work in in vacation
rentals for the last two years we're
moving more towards commercial real
estate at the moment but I'm pretty
well-versed and residential bull-riding
and what about your debt three years a
lot of it so he's not from this world
why is your dad and you going into
business so I have the energy to do
operations and he's incredibly good with
you know the numbers marketing and
so like those two dynamics love it all
so yes you got that next question family
businesses break down to two major data
points of contention one money to
respect do you have a sense if I said to
you there's a hundred percent to
allocate and one bucket is money and the
other one is credit the credit for being
good the credit for being better what
would you say your DNA is and then one
is your guests on your dad between money
and respect and credit let's start with
you as a human when it comes to money
[Music]
[Laughter]
you guys you guys you guys are very
boring if you're if you're if you're 60
if you're 55 to 75 percent credit and
he's a hundred percent credit
you two are wildly vulnerable because in
a world where it's gray you're both
gonna be fighting for the credit for the
growth and the results let me tell you
why I'm telling you this my me and AJ me
and my dad my two experiences over the
last 22 years me and my dad my dad on
credit and money I would argue is 20%
money 80% credit maybe me yet 20 80 I
would say that I'm five and ninety
five problems we overlapped a lot
fighting a lot right me and AJ I'm 5%
money 95% credit AJ is 95% money 5%
credit
great team awesome everybody want this
is the family business framework people
don't speak about it properly they don't
understand that it's money and credit
and the best family businesses overlap
in a way we're one values credit more
than money and vice versa
thus everyone's scratching their edge
there will be resentment ten years later
on both sides one would want a little
more credit the other wishes they got a
little more money but they're still
breathing and living successfully if you
and your dad overlap that much you must
sit down and have dinner with him show
him this video and speak at nauseam what
happens when you fight over credit and
you guys take a step back have a safe
word that stops the fight and then you
take a breath and have dinner and talk
it through communication is the only
prayer for you guys my relationship my
relationship with Mike my relationship
with my dad and my brother has never
been and can never be the same
since we went into business not pro or
con just truth your relationship with
your dad will never be the same after
you entered into this business together
yes but as the driver of both the money
and the credit having to give up won in
both scenarios wasn't delicious
yeah I appreciate you brother I wish you
a lot of success I hope you rewatch this
and really internalize it and I really
thank you for the credit question
because you asked it of me during a time
where I have more clarity on this than
ever because I don't just have my
experience I now have the benefit of
seven years of reading five thousand
different fifteen thousand different
interactions and observing its scale
I've been struggle I've been struggling
coming up with my next book and I think
it might be time for me to talk about
family business that I'm gonna wait for
a little bit longer as you know I've
thrown that out in the world for a long
time I think that's still a work in
progress but I think it might be time
for family business because I don't I
don't have a family business dynamic in
front of me for at least another 15
years before my children get of age to
even debate it so I think I might be
ready 11 copies brother have a great day
that's some good [ __ ] right there that's
some real good [ __ ] right there you know
why we have to do this improv like just
go live and do it is because when my
energies right like I'll cancel [ __ ] if
my Energy's right and move it around cuz
when my energy is this zoned in like it
like it just extra quick you and I
extracts much more thoughtful
understanding from me yeah this is where
I'm at my best coz I'm forced to go
deeper whereas when I'm talking in
general I have to go broad by nature to
bring the most value you know you know
so when I think about my Instagram or
things that nature I'm trying to bring
as much value to as many people as
possible but it can't be as specific
when I have time to breathe and I get a
very specific question I can go deeper I
know that we just literally help three
people who are gonna treat not and it
may seem too many that are just watching
they're in our situation oh wait I'm not
gonna do
it's not bad it's going into it with
eyes wide open it actually may lead to
more people doing it because they're
going in eyes wide open because
everyone's scared to [ __ ] up the
relationship if they love them but I've
had a million conversation the other
person doesn't have the ability to
reciprocate you can talk to your mother
she can go a year without on it and then
you have to know what to do with that
so it's both hello I'll be with you in a
second and I'll be with you in one
second I'm just talking with d-roc okay
yep so so as you know I mean we talked
about the five a Boehner I have the
conversations in candor people don't
they yes me and then they act different
so it's arming the person to know what
the patterns are and giving them the
confidence to jump out I've been into
family businesses I'm not an either
right now hi how are you great how are
you
I'm super well where you from Texas what
part I live about 25 minutes eat salad I
love it give me one second everybody's
watching hey if you want this oh my god
moment like Hannah has two one two nine
three one five seven three one text me
if you've never signed up for my text
platform you'll get an automated reply
you just got to get the contact card
into your phone and locked in because we
don't want to spam and boom you're off
to the races
Oh Jim how do how did the text be sent a
week ago to let people go into little
little different buckets so that they
great will we're do top hashtags the ask
then how many people want it to whine oh
by the way preview because a lot of
people watching right now and I know
this later and a lot people to be pumped
about it
if you love wine actually let me start
that sentence over if you don't love
wine but you love how I roll and think
and you want to support my dad if you
also like high-end or medium and Trader
Joe's to like Wegmans to like specialty
gourmet food
something's brewing and it's good it's
real [ __ ] good and look for that
announcement soon so if you eat and you
can afford stuff that's of higher
quality but you love premium products at
ridiculous prices I'm entering your
world which can get a ton of people
under 21 the first time to be able to do
something with me which is very exciting
Hannah yeah what is your question
darling ah I guess I can only get that
one huh well if you go [ __ ] fascist
[ __ ] maybe we can give ton okay go to
your list and read them all and then I
will play Plinko board and answer as
many as I can
let me start with three very quick that
one's easy
if you don't judge yourself for being
inefficient you become efficient I might
be one of the most inefficient people of
all time but because I don't judge it I
actually become remarkably efficient if
people realize they spend more time
dwelling on being inefficient than
actually the efficient work everything
would change no [ __ ] that's why you
asked it first and I'm being really
serious with a I'm going to sit on this
one for it's gonna help a lot of people
everybody judges themselves arbitrarily
all of a sudden everybody thinks they're
an efficiency expert on them own self
all you're doing is driving home
insecurities and judgment on yourself on
something that doesn't matter doesn't
mean try not to get more efficient but
just doing what you can like having a
calendar and doing the best you can is
just fine
the second you don't get to something on
your calendar and you beat yourself up
is a second your inefficient mm-hmm
macro inefficient mm-hmm that makes
sense I make a lot of them I mean you
can't like I was supposed to be in
Singapore right now but coronavirus came
out I decided not to go right cuz some
angst that the kids and mom level I was
like [ __ ] it I'll stay now I'm here and
we a couple things have happened where
I've been
bunch of pockets of time I just had what
the admins this morning and we're
scrambling to like make it efficient as
possible we should have a great system
in place where we absolutely know what
my 43 priorities are but we don't let me
time do and it's kind of my head that's
coming in their head and over the next
48 hours I mean they're gonna make it
really efficient high impact on the time
I had or not but on Wednesday morning
whether we did or didn't I'm not gonna
give a [ __ ] cuz it's over mm-hmm the
dwelling that people put on themselves
around efficiency is overwhelming to me
and you know Chris at best and dangerous
at worst mm-hmm next that makes a lot of
sense thank you for that you're welcome
following up that question what advice
did you give for a recovering adult do
this who is always told they were
special to the child that now realize
that overall they're really just average
by being pumped as [ __ ] about being a
human being yeah perspective I'm with
you listen you know you're asking me a
hot-button topic for me question cuz you
know my stuff that's okay a a eliminate
all anger or resentment at your parents
eliminate all of it I I have no anger
toward love great next great light I'm
not even 99% of people have that problem
so that since you don't let's move on to
the next one number two with in this
answer the who gives a [ __ ] framework
okay like what does that mean like so
you're not special yes you were and no
you aren't like like in a lot of ways
Beyonce special in a lot of ways she's
not mm-hmm a lot of ways Hannah is a lot
of ways you're not and who's judging the
specialness what confirmation
affirmation are you looking for actually
how about let's play this game Hannah
why can't you be something let's play it
a different way let's make pretend you
are instead of not don't be delusional
you know that's not as
delusional like that you can be anything
you want is not real you can you cannot
be a world-class rapper or skier or
painter if you want to if you do not
have natural talent to make you the best
in the world right however you can you
could go after all three of those if
you're willing to be happy that you did
mm-hmm you could yeah I know it's true I
I don't think he's got enough time we
put [ __ ] sucks
and Elon Musk and [ __ ] you know Meg
Whitman on pedestals why don't we start
putting you know Sally who's a ski
instructor who makes 49k air because at
13 she decided she loves skiing had the
humility at 16 to realize she's not
going to the Olympics but then realized
happiness was the only way to actually
live your [ __ ] life and move to Aspen
and started from the bottom and got to a
$63,000 a year job being a ski
instructor at a Tier three ski place and
lives by her means and his happiest [ __ ]
every day of her life why can't we put
her on a [ __ ] pedestal maybe because
our self-image is so low and she's just
more relatable than Elon love so Ilana
is that lady becomes cooler of course
but that's our insecurities manifesting
[ __ ] those right my husband doesn't
believe me what's his name Daniel hey
Daniel what's up bro it's really me bro
this is not an automated message it's
really me bro I promise no it is cool
you're cool either where Heuer [ __ ]
that fires me the [ __ ] up it does I love
Daniel do you love horseshoeing
I do my man and I love you for that
brother Hey
yeah what else you got okay okay what
else do you have that clue you in and
eating surest or recharged and going off
of that how you maximize interesting to
be able to hit the ground running
right after great question people are
very good at lying to themselves I try
not to and when I feel tired
I sleep symbols that like yeah and I'm
programmed and I've got tons of
responsibilities and I hack I look at
what's in front of me and I hack I
figure it out at all cost in your
example you look at good-looking Daniel
and say [ __ ]
tomorrow morning I'm sleeping to 11 a.m.
see ya yeah like bouncing back from
adversity yeah I look I think this is
about gratitude this is why I push it so
hard right even my last answer was
self-awareness some people like I don't
even know what's happening I'm like I
understand let's keep focusing on self
awareness like I'm able to bounce back
from everything and anything cuz I'm
grateful right right you're gonna tell
me what went wrong I'm gonna tell you
what won right you're alive you will
never you will never beat me in a debate
I do believe well good then you should
be bout it I don't know if you believe
that if you're asking the question
because if you believe that you 100%
have the capability 100% of time to
bounce back mm-hmm yeah I think I think
it was just like you know we spent a
year like pushing ourselves into the
ground like grinding yes like we just
understand that like we just a thought
for us yep and so it ended up is at the
end of you know that 12 months we were
so burned out we were like the most
miserable people you've ever had do you
know why Hannah because we are grateful
nope because you weren't patient enough
Oh see I have a lot of natural energy
and I go hard but because I think about
life in a 54 year a 73 year window a 94
year window I don't think about it in
one-year terms
Hannah do you know the number one thing
I do that disappoints my fan base my
friends
my community the people that like me the
number one thing do you know what the
number one thing I do that disappoints
the [ __ ] out of them Cheerilee what I
deliver the sentence I can watch their
face go from excitement and admiration
to disappointment do you know what that
is no it's what I tell them I'm gonna
buy the Jets in 31 years not next year
oh they want it now so did you write
Rick is right and we say [ __ ] in these
parts the reason the reason you got
there was because you actually did
people don't get it they see me going
hard that's fueled by gratitude most
people are fueled by lack of patience
the reason I never will burn out is
because I don't allow it because I'm too
patient and too grateful if I wanted the
Jets next year I would start doing manic
energy [ __ ] that would lead me to
burnout yeah I love the process not the
things that I get out of my process you
are I'm actually not even that
interested in buying the Jets I'm
interested in the game of trying to buy
the Jets which allows me to never
actually burn out or not have resentment
or or pain when I an 89 and it becomes a
wildly aware to me that I can't buy the
Jets I'm not in it for the million
dollars I'm not in it for the Jets I'm
in it for feeling great about my process
leaving good along the way that leads to
admiration and a reputation and respect
and legacy and having fun every day
along the way if I wasn't gonna do that
if I didn't care about that I would
never go to a sports car show for an
entire week in the last week of July
because that's not gonna be ROI positive
through the years over the last decade
so many people judge me for my behaviors
they're like that's not gonna help me
get the Jets that's not gonna help you
get
Jetts that's not gonna help him get the
Jets because they're not listening to me
just cuz I was just cuz I have a
professional business goal doesn't mean
that I'm anxious or disappointed if it
doesn't happen I love the game people
get burned out because they wanted to
fast or they care about other people
watching them
I mean burned out everyday if I took in
the judgment of the outside audience
yesterday 90% of the advertising
industry was making fun of me on Twitter
because they made a subjective call on
our three Superbowl commercials and if I
took that to heart I'd be upset today
instead of happy as [ __ ] because their
opinions don't matter the business
results do right oh good we're moving up
the ranks I like this we went from frick
to hack let me keep talking I might get
you to [ __ ] I have to go because my
admins are staring at me in an evil way
but I love you and I hope you rewatched
us and really understand what we're
talking about Thank You Hannah have a
great day and tell Daniel I love him
give him a big kiss in the mouth for me
I did yeah I love it
take care Hannah bye-bye that's the
askgaryvee show we're [ __ ] back
[Music]